I want to start a family with you I
don't think it's fair to our children to
put them through the loss of a father at
such a young age which is something that
I went through wouldn't it be unfair to
not give your kids the best father you
say like he's already going to be aming
father it's like having a pet you
worship those years that you had with it
it's like having a pet Oh my days this
is a
sickness of the highest order these
people do not want to be parents
they want to have kids they want to have
a
possession I'm Cheryl McCain and I'm 63
years old hey 63s and you
80 my mom 70 she don't look like that yo
I'm Kar McCain and I am 26 years old and
we have a 37 year age cout so think
about that she was 36 when this man was
in his dad's
balls if you're truly in love does AG
really matter I'm K Takahashi and in
today's K Takahashi that's not that's
not what I
heard what you he my name is [__] takaha
shake up die God damn they really did
you dirty on the name dog they didn't
you co what [__] [__] C my bad I really
the first prompt is my partner is the
best I've ever had in bed go ahead and
turn around
wow look at
this you bunch of liars it's okay I
respect it Cheryl you are dancing for
joy why don't you go ahead and start I
keep
happy is great with him I was his first
which I didn't know she looked like she
could remove her teeth so yo that got me
that got me job is wow until later on
was he good on the first time yes it and
I would have never
known yo we got tales of the [__]
creeper in the building this [__] is
wild she just oh she's melting when I
first met her we were in the bathroom
and I forgot what happened I'm going
tell it but um I pre- ejaculated over
her legs like you know I was just like
rubbing against her and I just all over
his name is
Quran but I never heard some so much
Haram
his name is
Kuran God damn Jeff he's uh Trey's the
best you've ever been with huh yeah
absolutely uh and that's saying
something cuz I'm a gay man and you know
that's lived through the 80s 90s and the
2000s so that's a lot of guys so yeah
yeah uh I'm a
[__] hi my name is John and I'm 29
years old and I'm Brian I'm 63 and
you're going to make me do math so my
man was 23 and they met and he was in
his late 50s
yes it' be like that Hey listen these
are consenting adults so I can do these
faces all I want and they're free to do
what they want but this is a sickness
and any not my family but everyone else
is free to do what they want I think
it's just funny when I hear something
like this only because I'm like bro you
were 30 when this [__] was B that math
is crazy in my head he was done this
Daddy's nut sex while you was balls
deeping hundreds of dudes by the point
you was in your 30 that's crazy but hey
everyone's allowed to do what they want
as adults yeah but it's still weird the
next prompt is my partner and I have
special sexual
fantasies okay go ahead and turn around
Quan you say yes chery says no what is
it I mean I say yes cuz I do like some
stuff I want to be a slave I ain't going
to flex I have a fantasy for that I'm
sorry
yo my man needs to change his name my
man needs to change his name my man
needs to change his [__]
name this is the most Haram [__] I've
ever seen you can't trust a [__] who
dies his hair blonde I just said that
all these Dennis Rodman Cisco looking
ass [__] cannot be
trusted every single one of them
including my roommate for the people my
people I'm sorry I'm just saying that
now it's not in the same way but it's
just like you ever had like little
mental thing where you like oh Master's
wife home alone I've be saying that to
her all the time she like shut up no why
do you say no I don't really have a
fantasy like that but if it happens and
we're doing it then how yeah this video
is brought to you by surf shark while
fresh and fit just pearly things and
every little loser in the red pill space
or taking L's we want you guys to get
some W's with today's sponsor surf shark
here's the thing a lot of stuff is
linked to your IP address and your
personal information right you want to
book a flight well depending on your IP
address you might get different rates
that's right if you try to book the
flight from London versus Brazil versus
Canada you're going to get three
different sets of prices depending on
the fair that you're trying to book with
the VPN changer you can optimize your
travel plans by making sure that they
cannot track your IP to give you an
unfavorable Fair what's more some
content is gated based off your location
why shouldn't you be able to watch the
TV shows and the movies you want to
watch when you got a subscription you
should be able to see it all just
changing your location with a VPN allows
you to do so and what's more if you're
going to be on public Wi-Fi if you're
going to be out here you need to protect
your information and so surf sharks VPN
service actually serves to protect your
devices what's more what makes surf
shark really special is that you can
connect multiple devices to the same
account it's now time for you guys to
take advantage and right now if you
click on the link below and use uh the
promo code I would preach you're going
to be able to have up to six months free
click on the link in the description
below it's your turn my family approves
of my partner make your split decisions
in 3 2
1 all right go ahead and turn
around okay back we got a lot of yes but
you know
my no it's just funny you the only one
over there well my family doesn't
approve of him and I don't care if they
do or not like I'm with him like it
doesn't make a difference I don't I have
seven children one child is there for
both of us only one is approves mhm of
the relationship yes because of they
call him the nword other
on
hey I don't even see what the problem
you like being a slave stupid what's the
issue I I don't even care like this dude
already had me to be some person's slave
like what you going to trip about the
nword want I act like you want some self
resect like come on get him out of here
hey you can only call me that if I'm
[__]
you that's weird and I'm not I'm going
to keep it a stack with you like if I'm
hers child okay and she like in her and
she want to bring and I'm supposed to
call this guy Dad she younger than me
yeah yeah don't ask crazy nah n no no no
that's just not happening that's not
happening your other kids call him the
for no reason I'm happy I've showed them
this they don't care they don't care
about my happiness apparently I don't
talk to seven of six of six of my
children because of your relationship
yeah and it hurts me but I love him I
love them too but I love them from a
distance I'm not going to give up
somebody that I searched for all my life
that I found peace and everything the
reason you couldn't find it for so long
cuz he was in his dad's balls it's hard
and you you searching and he not even
born yet you in your late 30s you
already had multiple kids I can want to
find the love of my life I think as a
parent you just don't have the right to
do that you shouldn't have the right to
do that drop being around your kids six
of them so you could be with some dude
who's 36
younger this just me yeah maybe I'm
being emotional right now but I don't I
I don't like that anything else and
happiness it makes me want to cry but my
kids go I done did everything for them
cannot do no more why can they not
approve it hurts me daily how does that
impact you makes me emotional like
really like I ain't never felt love like
that before like from the time I met her
she literally quit her job because they
were and they said they didn't want an
nword dancing in the store and she quit
her job just met her she didn't want an
nword dancing in the
store I mean I don't want no [__]
dance in my store woman man white don't
matter but
like he's just visiting
so were you guys filming Tik
toks were they filming Tik toks I think
that might be why you dancing in her
store if they're if they're out here
dancing
yo they was dancing in the store hey yo
I have fired her ass too that was just
pretty awesome the fact that her own
kids they have caught me in word and
stuff it hurts cuz it's like wow like I
do love her but she been abused she been
married twice no you know this is
actually worse now that I've seen the
Tik Tok cuz like you embarrassing Us in
the whole family online doing this
gimmicky ass [__] that's so [__]
nasty like you didn't have the decency
to keep this [__] offline now I got to
go to Every function like is that your
mom with the oh hell no nah bro I'm
sorry no my family accept Cheryl though
wholeheartedly she comes to the cookout
barbecues and they treat her like normal
they do I bet they do when they y'
making money off this [__] freak Show
barue but yeah that does made me feel
some way I know you want your kids to be
there as a parent but we just can't get
them on the same track as us it hurts me
that I had to turn my back on him but I
have my husband
now these people make me
sick I can see that this is the only
part about this whole thing I don't care
about what these two you know the slave
master stuff okay whatever
is the whole family portion of this
that's really gross I'm worried my
partner might leave me for someone their
own age okay go ahead and turn
around y'all are confident love yeah the
way that old lady moves is every time
she has an answer she likes I I know I
know what you think I know what you
think she like this I know what you
think I know what you think the way that
old lady moves what what I think she
done crack all right what I think she
done
crack that's what you
think she move like noodles
bro yeah she be moving Funk okay well
have you all ever fantasized about your
partner being your own age absolutely
honestly I never see her age so I just
feel like we're the same age until she
get hurt or anything like literally we
do everything the same and it's all
normal so I don't see her age until
she's hurt or something you know I think
in age Gap relationship like living in
the moment living each day yeah we might
not be able to plan 40 years from now
cuz what will I be in 40 years like so I
think these kinds of Dynamics are fine
for what they're describing which is
living in the moment for family related
stuff this doesn't seem
tenable because like we always talk
about single parent household this and
that but like you marry someone 30 40
years you're your senior by the time
your kids hit like teenage years or God
forb you in adulthood one of the parents
is like going to be
so that's just one of those things like
you know we've been joking and laughing
about but I'm glad they're having a very
mature discussion about it but it's also
important to realize like for a
relationship purpose 30 to 40 year age
Gap is
wild you know 20 to 50 okay you know if
you start kids young maybe but it's just
like 20 to 15 you're saying 50 20 to 50
so like one partner's 20 one 50 like can
you guys have kids you know I guess but
it's like by the kids hit 20 like one of
them is already gone
like you have to think about what you
doing to the children through that
relationship yeah you know you're
putting the bab also you might be
putting the burden of your own care you
know as you get your ill years before
your kids have even started college so
your kids are going to University one of
their parents is like struggling to get
into a care home or whatever it is is is
is a bit of a dark thing to think what
you do today changing diapers your
kids's 20
husband that's
crazy mhm HB been you know like I'm I'm
okay now if my mom God forbid everything
happens to her healthwise you know she's
only like late 50s but like something
did happen I'm at a place in my life
right now where financially I can handle
it yeah if I was back in my 20s having
to have that stress over my head like
there was no way I'd feel good about
that kind of stuff so but again not
everybody's trying to have a family so
this is a completely different
conversation but you know what I mean
like we really like we really like doing
stuff like this and traveling and just
all the fun stuff that we get to do it's
like we're doing it's like oh let let's
plan that 10 years from now we might not
have it I mean he could get hit by a bus
doesn't mean like that I'm going to go
first I think about having a full life
with you all the time and a lot of
people have said about kids and I really
want to I want you to be my husband and
we want I want to Father with you I see
how you treat your nephews and nieces
and it's so special and that's really
bad for us because is I can't have no
more babies MH and he doesn't have any
and of course I want to give him that so
like I can't that we talked about that
before we even got married like I can't
be selfish because we're we talked about
it and I can't have no babies but we're
we've been looking and trying with SAR
gets for what a year and a half almost
two years almost two years now so we are
working on it and it doesn't matter how
old I am because I have seven kids and I
could take care of kids no matter what I
take care of my grandbabies he's a
grandpa of 17 um grandchildren 18 now
cuz we just found out one and they all
call and stuff and Pops I see how she
interact with them and they all love it
they love to come to our house so it's
like I know she's fit she got years
ahead of her I don't care what nobody
say age doesn't mean nothing
so okay this episode went from good
nasty weird to these people are [__]
insane there's something mentally wrong
with them sorry I don't like to be that
kind of but the way that they're talking
about ages just a number when he just
earlier said oh I don't notice her age
until she has health problems like
honestly I never see her age so I just
feel like we're the same age until she
get hurt or anything like literally we
do everything the same and it's all
normal so I don't see her age until
she's hurt or something just This
Woman's pushing 70 and this dude's
talking about having kids with her like
she going to be around much longer I
don't know age doesn't mean nothing so
we can plan far but once we had a child
you know no telling how life is going to
bring us and take us cuz you can't I
don't think of that you don't want to
think ahead too far cuz you can't think
about tomorrow cuz you don't know what's
going to happen tomorrow so we just live
in the moment literally uh I don't want
to take too far ahead I want to raise a
child what the [__] are you on look I'm
not telling people they got to plan
their whole future you're talking about
bringing a child into this world yeah
you should do some planning you should
do some budgeting you should do some
figuring things out is that crazy thing
to ask like
I there's the same people that say oh my
God I didn't know it would be so much
yeah cuz you didn't
plan I I I I hate stuff and that's the
difference between having a baby and
wanting to be a parent they want a baby
they they want a baby they want to have
a possession haha we have a baby we are
at that point in our life but we don't
want to project ourselves in if you yeah
you don't want to be a parent cuz being
a parent is exactly about that putting
yourself aside and projecting for the
future that's what what a parent is
that's what a parent does y you want a
baby and like here's the thing that you
rob your kids of and this is just a
personal thing you rob your kids of a
friendship because you never have that
look listen your early years when you
have the kid you're essentially just a
caretaker the kids are [__] [__]
everywhere whatever afterward you start
disciplining the kid trying to guide
them to make sure they're decent human
beings and then afterwards you're really
like coaching them right when they're in
their teenage years like you're still
very involved but you can't be holding
them like you were when they're four
it's a bit different and then they get
to their adult years and they go from
just being your child to also like
starting to be your friend cuz all
having adult conversations right you're
talking about kids you're talking about
having um taxes bills Investments all
these other things you Robb them of that
entire period because you just want to
have that but it's like that's been one
of my favorite periods with my parents
that transition from they're just seeing
me as a child to like now we're friends
that we're on equal level we're never
goingon to have that if if my mom is
already in her 80s because I go from
essentially teenage years to being a
caretaker right away and it's a huge
amount of Burden financially emotionally
physically like being a caretaker for an
aging parent when you have no financials
and you have no flexibility in your life
is one of the most difficult things so I
don't know it's just when these people
talk about they don't care they don't
think about these things to me it just
sounds so incredibly selfish and
inconsiderate of the children they're
trying toing this world it's crazy like
you guys could have adopted you know
kids in their adult years something
but it's like I don't know adulterers
kids in their late team that's being
very selfish super and that's what I
mean by they want a kid not being they
don't want to be a parent I agree and he
has he pushed for monogamy and I was I
stood back from it because I'm like I
don't think you're I don't think you're
ready for it I don't think you're ready
for cuz my body is so po delicious
baby I want to start a family with my
partner someday make your split
decisions in 3 2
1 okay go ahead and turn
around okay almost all of us say yes
that's a shocker John you say no you
want to speak on that I want to start a
family with you I don't think it's fair
to our children oh my God
finally holy [__] someone said it I am
so happy you know what live your best
lives together I think this is the most
respectable and amazing thing has been
said this whole [__] episode the only
respons let I think it's fair to our
children to put them through the loss of
a father at such a young age which is
something that I went through and I
don't I guess that's my own lived
experience biasing this um that would
that's a lot to go through so I just as
much as I know that you'd be an awesome
father I just don't think it's fair to
the kids yeah and I I get that and it's
almost more cuz like I want to do it for
you type thing you know and I know it's
it's it's uh it would kind of be unfair
but like my mom's 98 not that a
20-year-old wants to have a 98y old dad
or something but you know yeah your mom
is 98 now but you're [__] whatever
that means that you
had your time with your mom I've
constantly think about it cuz I think we
would be great parents we totally would
and I know we would make it work but
it's I I understand not wanting to put
your kids through that loss like imagine
like going through college and you know
you have a definite family but the flip
side wouldn't it be unfair to not give
your kids the best father you say like
he's already going be amazing hey you
know fathers are only great if they're
actually alive and around especially if
they in bed the whole time and out of
commission or in the retirement home
Alzheimer's whatever it is
like and I mean it's like having a pet
you worship those it's like having a pet
Oh my days
yo y'all got me [__] up hey yo about
y'all got me you can shut that [__] up
he said it's like having a pet you can
shut that [__] off he confirmed what I
said earlier which is these people do
not want to be
parents they want to have kids they want
to have a possession the same way that
they have a bracelet a pet a thing that
you put in a bag and then in seven years
it's dead we buy another one oops that
thing got away [__] out of here that
they do not they do not want to be yo y
preachers cold with
it that was cold let's finish this video
Oh my days these people are SI it's like
having a pet this is a
sickness of the highest order that is a
long time this is DAV I haven't
therefore we do not want it we kind of
miss you we have made a decision today
to buy this video from everyone these
people should never be allowed to have
children H they said they want to bring
a child into this world only so they can
exit that's right these people are sick
and you to you people out there that
think that your pet is the same thing as
a child it is not no it is not you may
feel that way but it is not nowhere near
comparable and if you have kids and pets
and you're saying that it's exactly the
same the same thing we should remove
them pets all that's it you worship
those years that you had with it rather
than thinking about oh the downsides of
going without it at least give your kids
like the chance to have 18 years with
the best father that you can provide
[Music]
them I really wish you should shut that
[__] down maybe we start with a dog
yeah are you are you a hard no could you
be convinced I could totally be
convinced I think if if you're all in
I'm all in but I just again my biased my
lived experience is that it's a lot to
go through the loss of a loved one of a
parent like that and yeah cuz you lost
your dad Young so yeah and I think
that's why in this relationship and an
age Gap relationship you have to cherish
every day and that's also it makes it
magical because you know there is
somewhat of an expiration date on it and
while I don't think it would be fair to
the children yeah it's also unfair to us
I I think we would be awesome dads you
kidding me I'm glad to hear that you
would do it for me and with me and like
I said I've seen you with the nieces and
nephews and you are a kickass human
and
so does our time here together change
your
answer
awesome I hope he's just doing that for
the cameras Trey Jeff how does it impact
you both knowing that your future is you
know cut short by the age Gap that's
something we have talked about we have
focused on I mean just the other day we
were I asked them can you write down
baby names for
me because it's the which made me want
to S actually I know I want to have a
family regardless and I want to have it
with him but I don't want his memory to
be lost on my children cuz he's been the
most impactful person in my whole life
and just then he was like I promise you
we're going to have kids together and so
everything like you ask me about if time
is fleeting you know how do I grapple it
I don't grapple with it anymore because
and it might be in two years three years
four years we're going to have a little
baby boy that can say papa Trey and papa
Jeff all right well this is it for
today's mental health episode
um very
disturbing and I don't see that about
pretty much any video on YouTube that
was actually genuinely disturbing yeah
apparently that old lady she met him
when he was 16 and she was 64 so they
known each other since as teenagers Hey
listen I'm not even going to get into
that AC forget it there's a lack of a
lot of things there so whatever it is
what it is man yeah uh let us know what
you guys think in the comments below God
damn